miss malotte hamdulillah
assalam-o-alaikum
how are you doing it's Ramadan and I had
a story to share with you I thought
there'll be some great benefits and
addressing this issue so be like kind of
my vlog you guys can kind of get to know
me and see what goes through my mind and
the material that I come up with the
things that my computer is dissecting
and I had a situation the other day come
up and I thought it was very important
for me to address this I was at lunch I
wasn't having lunch because obviously
I'm fasting but I was with some friends
of mine giants in their field some
really great guys and you know this
month I've been talking about Muhammad
Ali American Muslim hero and somehow in
our conversation they're eating I'm
sitting back having nice conversation
benefiting from their experience my
friends that I was with not yet Muslims
and one of them this is what stimulated
me to want to talk about this I wanted
to make a point of integrity I wanted to
take make a point of standing firm for
beliefs and then how when times change
people respect that and that was the
great quality of Muhammad Ali he was an
enemy of the state at one time and then
now he became a legend a hero because he
stand he stood on what was good good
solid ground on goodness this is an
example for all of us I try to make that
point and then somehow in the
conversation my friend let's call him
Jimmy great guy and he mentioned
something about Muhammad Ali being
connected to the KKK Ali was the
mouthpiece for a religious group that
shared the same beliefs as the white
supremacist the Ku Klux Klan
and both organizations met regularly to
discuss a possible pact Ali even spoke
at a Klan rally and ahead of the fight
Manila boasted about the experience hell
of a scene all these white hoods on the
bonfire and me on the platform and Ozzy
Krantz was talking I says black people
should marry their own women
I said blue birds are bluebirds Red
Birds with rippers pigeons with pigeons
Eagles with Eagles God didn't make no
mistake is he yeah that's all you teach
the rest of Negroes that never be ours
normally we had a funny thing happened
one of them says we got the [__]
strain you up and I'm looking at jump
baby one of them came out with a rope
he's a we're just joking child let me go
now I know I'm sure his intention wasn't
bad there he had come across he really
knew all his fights but he brought this
up and I'm sure there's a lot of people
out there I think this is some kind of
double standard how can this guy end up
being a American hero and they connect
him to somehow being a racist because he
was connected with the KKK so if you
look into this you'll see that there was
something that went on with the nation
Elijah Muhammad and the KKK and that's
what I'm going to address in this video
and I thought it's going to be very
important because it's real simple to
disqualify that claim which is a true
claim at that time but at the end he
ended up leaving the nation which and
simple and in summarizing has nothing to
do with with Islam and that's what I'm
going to I'm going to get into Malcolm X
another legend another giant we're going
to get into a concise version of you
know how this all started
both of their trips with Malcolm and
Muhammad Ali
so then other people who have this doubt
this misconception not knowing the whole
version because this is very confusing
for a lot of people
nation and true Islam and then they put
the two together and it's just confusing
so let's address that all right let's
get started now again very short I'm
going to try to keep it concise guys can
go and look into this a little bit
further make a long story short back in
the 1930s around 1935 you had Elijah
Poole Elijah Muhammad nothing to do at
all with the last and final messenger
the Prophet Muhammad had been of the law
sallallahoalyhiwasallam who was the last
and final messenger sent to mankind
fourteen hundred years ago
nothing to do with him this is in the
1930s not around 1935 he hooks up with
Wallace fought Muhammad now some people
say he was Afghani maybe Pakistani he
looked white and this guy was teaching
allegedly is like seemed like he was
giving Dawa he was sharing Islam with
Elijah Muhammad he was teaching it but
as soon as someone learns the basic
simple fundamental message of Islam you
see that Elijah Muhammad he took this
because from around 1935 1940 all the
way till 1975 he was the one who took
off and created this whole nation I
don't even like to say Nation of Islam
just that the miss Aslam they missed
Islam by a longshot
because one of the fundamental teachings
of Islam is Towe heed the natural pure
monotheism if you just learn one chapter
in the Quran cool who Allah who had
bismillah al-rahman al-rahim
well who along a handle a
wanna let merely do an immunity what a
miracle never won ahead and a simple
translation will go something like this
say he is Allah say he is God the
Almighty one unique uniquely one and
alone worthy were worship
self-sufficient he doesn't eat drink he
has no children he's not a man he's not
the father of anyone he begets not nor
is He begotten and there is nothing
comparable to him so now let's take that
- for hard Wallace Muhammad who was a
Afghani or white man and he walked to
earth
he ate food he's Pakistani he'll eat
somebody on e and after that he's got to
get that stuff out of him he's got to go
to the bathroom and they've even got mug
shots of him getting locked up and also
with some letters doing some grammatical
mistakes and I know the the arguments
people are also saying from the other
side no that wasn't him that was a
look-alike someone who looked like him
etc etc but at the end of the day if you
take it back to this ayah from the
verbatim or of God the Quran and this
just goes with with you know our innate
nature - you know it doesn't take much
explaining this just makes sense that
and there is nothing like unto him so
you're not unique any more if you got a
look-alike so this guy even if that's
not him who got locked up white guy you
claim he's God a human being with all
the human being deficiencies he's not
unique no more he's like the next human
being who has all the deficiencies as a
human being well basically that's just
it's bogus in his bunk in the first
tenant of Islam the toe he'd that we
only worship the Creator was unseen
was all-knowing whose unlike his
creation who is one not a human being
and now you take this man it's like some
people to end up taking Jesus peace be
upon him this mighty messenger as a
human being and most people they reject
us and that's that's the same thing here
but this was a Elijah Muhammad he was a
social reformer you give him credit
there he would take the pimps and the
prostitutes and the drunks and the
druggies and raise him up you know this
is a time that african-americans there
was a great injustice that was being
done to the african-americans they were
being oppressed by the white Caucasians
and this pulled this he gave them an
identity he uplifted them their spirits
and unfortunately he took Islam and
twisted it also and created created
another in response to that you know
started calling white people the devil
and this is another fundamental belief
in Islam that Islam came to Arab
eradicate racism and anyone who knows
the fundamental teachings of Islam knows
that this is something that Islam is
totally against that the Prophet
Muhammad peace and blessings be upon him
the actual
last and final messenger said there is
no difference between a white and a
black an Arab or a non Arab except in
taqwa in God consciousness and piety so
again this is another teaching that goes
against the teachings of the true Islam
and Malcolm X he was one who was with
the nation and he became spokesman for
them he was up in the ranks and after
some time what happened was in essence
of time and summarizing he ended up
getting they put me out and they put me
out because of what I knew and what I
knew was told to me by mr. Muhammad's
son Wallace Muhammad himself they put me
out and they put him out told that he
could
speak for sometime and and while this is
happening so I'm going over at the same
time a little bit of the history and
then the conflicting the totally
conflicting teachings that anybody with
just a simple knowledge of the ABCs of
Islam will see that this nation miss
Islam they missed Islam totally so
Elijah Muhammad he ends up getting
Malcolm X on board Malcolm X becomes
strong advocate and shortly sometime
later Muhammad Ali he ends up also
joining the nation and long story short
Muhammad Ali he's with the nation and
he's also promoting this and what
happens is that Malcolm X in the
meantime years later he ends up being
called by Elijah Muhammad's son Wallace
D Muhammad and there's some news now
that he's bringing to him let's go to
this let's let Malcolm tell us for
himself what happened now if anyone had
come to me other than mr. Muhammad's son
I never would have believed it even
enough to look into it but I had been
around him so closely I had seen
indications of its of its uh of the
reality of it but my religious sincerity
made me block it out of my mind well in
1954 a teenage sister left Detroit and
became one of mr. Muhammad's personal
secretaries and there in the Chicago
office she became pregnant after being
there for a year and she was brought
before the Muslim community and
humiliated and isolated and a year a
year later another secretary this time
one from Lansing Michigan came to
Chicago she also became pregnant she was
brought before the community and
humiliated and isolated and because the
other person was never brought forth
during this court session it was
concluded by all of mr. Muhammad's
followers that it was a non-muslim who
was the other party while we
Rousseau rapidly and that in 1957 or 58
the secretarial staff was expanded to I
think eight teenage sisters in 1959 six
of them disappeared
two of them reappeared in Philadelphia
about two or three months later and they
were all right the other four reappeared
in 1960 all four of them had babies all
four of them had become involved with
someone and become pregnant and had
these children so it was from what I now
know when the four of them got back to
Chicago and begin to compare notes they
found that the same man had told all of
them the same story and had made all of
them pregnant that the same man was the
father of all four of their children and
had also been the father of the children
brought forth by the two secretaries who
preceded them so this story was kept
among these sisters until 1962 two of
them rebelled against the person who was
responsible and begin to tell the story
all over the city of Chicago it caused
many of the Muslims in the Chicago
mosque to leave and go back out in the
street they knew it and I knew nothing
about it
until 1963 when mr. Muhammad's son who
had been in prison came out and he was
he had been a minister and he was very
religious and spiritual and when he
began to hear these rumors around
Chicago he went to one of the sisters
and the sister admitted to him that the
rumor was true and it was he who first
told me about it and when he told me
about it I took I wrote to mr. Mohammed
and told him about it
and he admitted that he had a knowledge
of it and that he'd given me a religious
explanation that would fit into prophecy
and all of that so I was quiet and it
wasn't until October of 1963 that it
came up again and when it came up again
I realized that the same person who had
made these other sisters pregnant was
still busy doing the same thing he
hadn't stopped two of the sisters had
two children by the same man and one of
the two one of those two sisters was
pregnant still getting ready to have a
third child by the same man so when it
was known among the Chicago officials
that I had a knowledge of this they
become very fearful of me they became
very antagonistic toward me and they
tried they had to do something to de
many
the authority that I had for fear that
if this became public knowledge
the followers would leave the Muslim
movement and follow me
then it was at that time that they used
the statement that I made against
President Kennedy as a pretext to cut my
authority and some other things happen
that finally were produced to split or
force to split and when I made the split
the only reason that I didn't make this
public knowledge was I knew the
implications and I felt that if the
Muslims who were in the Nation of Islam
knew it that which enable them to be so
strongly religious and exercise moral
discipline would be shattered and it
would cause all of them to go right back
and start doing the things that they had
been doing previously who is the father
of all of these various children whom
you have enumerated ah the first one to
tell me who the father was was Wallace
Muhammad and he told me that the father
was Elijah Muhammad himself one of the
sisters - he went to the home of one of
the sisters and when he walked in the
door she said I want to let you see
something and she showed him her child
she said here's your brother and your
father is the one your father is the
father of this child and then ice
questioned the sisters myself because it
I was shook up and they admitted to me
that Elijah Muhammad was the father of
their children and I took it to him and
it was at that time he told me that he
was Muhammad the Prophet and that
Muhammad had nine wives he also told me
that he was David he was the modern
David than anything he was the modern
Solomon and that he was meant it was
meant for him to fulfill today all of
the things that they did back there and
how many of these illegitimate children
did he father with the sisters well he
made six sisters pregnant they all had
children two of those thick's had two
children uh one of those two is having a
child right now I am told that there is
a seventh sister who was supposed to be
in Mexico right now and she's supposed
to be having a child by him well these
revelations that you are now making
about Elijah Muhammad what effect should
they have on his following well I very
much doubt that any of his followers who
really are aware of what he has done
would continue to follow him
he may try and justify it by saying that
he's a Muslim a Muslim and that a Muslim
has a right to these wives if this were
the case he these sisters should not
have been humiliated these sisters have
been looked upon for the past five years
or six years or seven years as being
guilty of having committed fornication
they have been debased they have been
degraded I have heard he I have heard
him himself refer to them as having
disgraced him so if they were his wives
he should have given them a position of
respect so that all of his followers
would respect him and that they would
have his have the protection of his
followers today so after Malcolm hears
this news you know he can't believe it
he shocked this was his mentor his
teacher he believed that he was a
prophet which again we know that again
in the Quran 33 40 it clearly says that
Muhammad he is Prophet Muhammad he's an
he's not the father of any of you of any
of you but he is the last messenger the
seal of the prophets this is a clear
clear text amongst others but this is a
very clear text and you know you have
some groups that will try to twist this
meaning but anytime this is a
fundamental rule we have in Islam we
have the Quran this is the verbatim Word
of God or was revealed to Prophet
Muhammad over a span of 23 years then
just come down as a book drop from the
sky was a 23 years piecemeal memorized
by by millions living today and at that
time many had memorized it and then it
was preserved in the hearts also written
down on parchment Sun different things
that were available and then compiled
and we have it in its original and then
we have the teacher who was teaching us
how to interpret the Quran Allah sent
the messengers just like I always make
this example if you live in near the
time of Jesus he came with the injeel
and he was the one interpreting him
moses with the torah and he was the one
interpreting it muhammad he came with
the quran and he is explaining what this
actually meant so seal he made it clear
that he
no more messengers to come after prop
Muhammad so Elijah poor Elijah Muhammad
could not be a messenger this is totally
so that takes you outside of Islam you
missed Islam again
and we also have the understanding this
is another very important concept in
Islam that you have the Companions you
see you can want to play tricks with the
language but who understood the language
the best and what the Prophet saw some
meant when he said it like let me give
you example if you're hanging out with
me or I'm hanging out with you I know
your slang I know what you're saying
at this time go ahead and break a leg
let's be speed it up but maybe a
thousand years from now someone's quotes
you're saying that they might actually
break your leg you found me but no it
means hurry up speed it up and there's
other slayings examples that we can use
or terminologies metaphors so now how
did the Companions some people say
wouldn't mean companions we don't use
that word friends his best friends
homeys the people that were the closest
to problem Ahamed the Sahaba how did
they understand it for our for our you
know nation followers who might be
listening today understood it is clear
Prophet Muhammad peace and blessings be
upon him was the last and final
messenger so again this nullifies this
attempt for Elijah Muhammad to make
himself out to be a prophet now I'll go
ahead and mix these things in and and
give these evidences and you can kind of
see with the ABCs of Islam you see where
they missed Islam now through all the
myths of this Malcolm X he starts seeing
and putting the pieces together and with
this whole drama that happened and after
Elijah Muhammad's son comes in tells him
his news I knew nothing about it until
1963 when mr. Muhammad's son who had
been in prison came out and he was he
had been a minister and he was very
religious and spiritual and
he began to hear these rumors around
Chicago he went to one of the sisters
and the sister admitted to him that the
rumor was true and it was he who first
told me about it he's really traumatized
by this he puts it off for some time but
another five months later again Elijah
Muhammad's own son he comes and tells
him that the same thing is going on so I
was quiet and it wasn't until October of
1963 that it came up again and when it
came up again I realized that the same
person who had made these other sisters
pregnant was still busy doing the same
thing he hadn't stopped two of the
sisters had two children by the same man
and one of the two one of those two
sisters was pregnant still getting ready
to have a third child by the same man so
when it was known among the Chicago
officials that I had a knowledge of this
they become very fearful of me they
became very antagonistic toward me and
they tried they had to do something to
diminish the authority that I had and
then Malcolm X on his way out he's going
through all sorts of drama they tried to
wire his car and he was going to kill
you oh yes one of them was an attempt
was made to get one of them to wire my
car with an explosive they end up trying
to assassinate him ah I should have been
killed that my tongue should have been
put in an envelope and sent back to
Chicago by now well then then Clarence
the captain from Boston and John the
captain from Springfield came to New
York to assassinate me and came to him
to get a silencer and couldn't get it so
the police note is it's not something
that's new they just wait until the job
is done and then they step in you mean
he was going to kill you I wanted you to
know that my house was bombed it was
bombed by the Black Muslim
movement upon the orders of the 19
Mohammed now they had come around to
they had planned to do it from the front
and the back so that I couldn't get out
they had they they covered the front
completely at the front door then they
had come to the back but instead of
getting in directly in back of the house
and throwing it this way they stood at a
45 degree angle and tougher that the
window saw it it gland and went onto the
ground I don't know if I woke my husband
after he woke me up but I remember him
pushing me out of the bedroom door and I
looked to my right and I saw all of the
fire and the fire hit the window and it
woke up my second oldest baby and then
it but the fire burned on the outside of
the house but had that fire had that one
gone through that window it would have
fallen on a six-year-old girl a
four-year-old girl and a two-year-old
girl he went to hutch and it was only
after my trip into the Muslim world in
my pilgrimage to Mecca that I really was
able to exercise the objective approach
to it that enabled me to see that
something had to be done to bring this
to light otherwise a whole lot of
innocent people would be killed
needlessly he totally left the nation
and his life changed he saw no more did
he promote as he did before this white
man's a devil that hard Mohammed was a
law and carnate the man and the other
beliefs that the nation expounds and you
can you can see this this is in their in
their newspaper the final call to this
day they continued to promote this and
we wish the best of all their followers
a day that they like many the Giants of
the nation they ended up leading and we
have sahaja Hajj we have Mount Qasim on
many other captains even Elijah's own
son and another interesting thing that
we learn from Wallace D Muhammad
Elijah's son that Elijah's mother his
mother Allah also said that fraud
Muhammad he never claimed that he was
God check this out differed with my
father yes and I didn't want to differ
with him yes in fact I never
sniff it with him directly I was told he
was told that someone hurt me saying
something different so he called me to
question me about it and I told him that
I could more readily believe that he was
God that I could believe that his
teacher was God because his teacher was
a white man and he said wife you were
Devils and also I told him that I
understand something from your teacher
that makes me believe that he said those
things but he also left enough evidence
of his real intent and that was to bring
us to the correct idea of God in Islam
and for example my mother when I was
leaving the home one day after my father
had insisted that I accept God the way
he presented God or I was going to be
cut off from all communication he told
me he knew would hurt me to know that I
wouldn't data to see my mother he said
you won't be able to talk to your mother
I'll see her so I didn't change and as I
was leaving my mother was hurt and it
hurts me to see her hurting like that
she said she walked me to the door
because she didn't do that was normal
for her when my father excuse you she
and she stood on the porch at the door
and she said Wallace why don't you go
back there and accept it just say you
believe I said mama tell me what mr.
farrar told you all I said did he tell
you he was God and she looked like a
Faceman blinking it looked like she
didn't know what to say and a few
seconds she said no he did not say in
fact he told us to not even call him
prophet said that was too big a title
for him then I said to my mother how can
you ask your son now to accept a man as
God who told you prophet was too big a
title for him so in the midst of all
this Malcolm X he comes back from Hajj
he denounces the teachings of the nation
who missed Islam and he starts his
new path Mohammad Ali not right away
sometime later after Malcolm X is
assassinated he ends up also leaving the
nation and that's why it's kind of sad
today you know in the media you'll see
when they show pictures of Muhammad Ali
those you'll see that you'll notice the
caps I don't know if they intentionally
do this and it says foi the fruit of
Islam and many people don't know that he
left that's why I wanted to make this
video to make it very clear and this
answers the question with the KKK how we
started off than in the beginning that
because the nation who missed Islam they
end up advocated they were advocating
white man's a devil does racism and it's
all stemmed and rooted from the white
oppression but pure Islam the real Islam
submission to the crater not the
creation the way of life that Jesus
lived Moses Abraham this is a
continuation from the first man Adam got
out of his love he sent guidance and
that guidance was always the same
submits your will to the Creator and
submit your will to the Creator inquire
peace is one word is Islam and a Muslim
is one who does that action of Islam now
Muhammad Ali he ended up leaving this
and he denounced those teachings he left
the nation and he came to the true Islam
and then we have other teachings that
again Elijah Muhammad being a prophet
this is false I gave you the textual
evidence and also we know that you know
Allah he is the most loving and
forgiving and but the one thing that if
a person dies on you might have been
worshipping Jesus you might have been
worshipping fraud Muhammad but right now
you see this and you realize hey that
doesn't make sense a human being like me
and you who releases gas eats food who
gets tired you know during this blessed
month of Ramadan your fasting and you
start getting weak you start getting the
slumber overtakes you
slumber overtook him also man God
doesn't as he says and I had to Krissy
no slumber no sleep he created the hem
in the earth and no fatigue overtook him
the entire thing is simple maybe catch
up on the flu God didn't have a
nationality nor a birthdate this is
straightforward and simple this is why
people gravitate they have an affinity
to Islam the natural way and this is the
the number one thing that people love
about it that there's no superstitions
no strange incantations not as weird and
crazy stuff that's another point that's
very important that you know you if
you're new to Islam if you're if you're
looking for the way that's from the
crater one is to ask God Almighty for
guidance and another thing is as soon as
you start seeing you know Islam is based
on proof and evidence and there is
nothing in it that that that you get
repulsed with you know we have a lot of
people taking advantage of people like
you had this thing with Elijah Poole
with the secretaries and whatnot as
Malcolm talks about as soon as someone's
trying to use religion you know to
exploit women someone using religion you
know putting their their their hand on
your lap massaging you caressing you got
a lot of sick stuff going on out there
run from it somebody you may be in a
circle and you're doing some mystical
dancing and you know I mean what what is
this anything that just you're kind of
stands out is weird it's it's it's
probably has nothing to do with Islam
most likely has nothing to do with Islam
and if it does there's got to be textual
evidence that's the beautiful thing
about about the way of life from the
crater that it's based on evidence and
proof and when these giants when
Muhammad Ali wanted to go to the next
level Malcolm X also they started to see
that the you will always see people who
make certain claims as being prophets or
whatnot they'll always contradict
themselves they won't have the backing
of the Almighty
their movements won't grow they'll end
up being recognized by the people as
falsehood and that's what happened here
people recognized that they left it
and and before I cut out the thing I
wanted to try got sidetracked was that I
was saying that Allah is the most
merciful the most loving and even if
let's say you were worshiping you you
you know these men it's interesting that
fraud Muhammad is actually you know a
white guy and you know he looks white
and then you say white man as a devil is
contradiction upon contradiction and the
human being will always try to use the
use a lot of the Bible and they mix
things up to you know try to justify
their claims these this is this
deviation but the natural way the way
from God it's it's straightforward it's
based on on on common sense you know
it's based on on on on what God has
given you of intuition to recognize it
as a truth and when you're asking the
Creator Allah for guidance he'll
facilitate the way that you'll see
through all of this and then there's
there's a powerful many powerful ayahs
in the Koran one in particular in
Chapter four 116 I was saying that even
if you were worshiping a human being
you're committing what's called shidduch
but you repent from that because God is
able to forgive all sins but if you die
upon that this is something that we
don't as Muslim say okay you as an
individual you're going to Hellfire
unless God has specifically stated that
called someone out in the Quran but we
say in generality someone who sets up
partners with God this is mentioned in
the Bible and clear in the Quran that
this person will be forbidden paradise
for instance God Almighty is saying in
chapter 4 116 God doesn't forgive the
sin of making others equal with him but
he forgives any other sin besides this
for whomsoever He wills whoever it makes
equal with God has made a huge mistake
and gone far astray so this is something
very very dangerous setting up an equal
partner with God the simple message is
to only worship God only worship the
Creator and I hope that this benefits
those who had this
fusion again I could have just summed it
up and ended with Malcolm X and Muhammad
Ali at the end they laughed the nation
who missed Islam they also have so many
other teachings that contradict the the
true Islam and we pray that they end up
you know we have love for all of mankind
we hope that maybe some of the the
nation they they they listen to this and
and they watch some of the programs we
did with some of their captains
you know Qasim cansado Hajj these were
some of the upper echelon in that
movement even Elijah Muhammad son who
left Wallace D and I even heard from the
captain from Qasim Iman Kassam conduct
Elijah before he had Elijah for Elijah
Muhammad before he had died that he also
denounced it he pushed people to to read
the Quran to go towards the Quran and
the Sunnah and anybody who goes if
you're a follower of Elijah Muhammad you
go directly you go to the Quran and the
teachings of the last and final
messenger problem have a peace and
blessings be upon them there is no way
you can reconcile the two if you're
sincere you'll see that there's a big
problem here you'll recognize the
discrepancies and you'll end up if you
have a sincere heart and you're asking
God alone to guide you God will guide
you to what Malcolm X may God have mercy
on him was guided to true Islam but the
American Muslim hero Muhammad Ali who
left these ideas who missed Islam but
then God Almighty because he had been
seeking the truth God guided him the
true Islam the Islam that Moses was upon
Abraham was upon Jesus was upon and the
last and final messenger muhammad peace
and blessings be upon him giving of the
law sallallahoalyhiwasallam he was upon
and that's that islam of submission and
surrender to god almighty alone that
natural and pure monotheism and as we
started with an ayah from the Quran
that should be a measuring stick surah
flus bismillahi r-rahmani r-rahim well
who along I had a long holiday let me
really do it emulate what a miracle
everyone had say he is Allah the
absolute the eternal one and unique say
he is Allah though uniquely one the
absolute the eternal he gets not nor is
He begotten meaning that he has no
children he's not a human being he's not
the father of anyone he's
self-sufficient meaning that he doesn't
need food need air as these people who
are human beings who walked the earth as
Jesus did as Prato Hamid did they get
air if you would just put your hand over
their mouth they would have suffocated
this is not God man this stuff is just
weird doesn't make sense
God is above and beyond his creation he
created creation but he's not in his
creation he's monitoring it he knows
everything
these people if you asked them maybe to
multiply certain numbers certain
equations they wouldn't be able to
figure it out you'll tell him things
about the future they wouldn't know but
God knows everything everything this is
the almighty and he is unlike anything
or anybody that can be a double of God
there's nothing no one that even
resembles God so I hope that was a
benefit this short and concise summary a
little bit about how the nation started
and Malcolm X involvement and then
bringing I'm Muhammad Ali and then both
of them eventually coming to Islam
denouncing these teachings that
contradicted and had nothing to do with
the true Islam look into Islam and
you'll be amazed you'll find that peace
purpose satisfaction that the heart is
looking for because it's from the
Creator it makes sense it has to make
sense but are you looking and are you
sincere because if you are and then you
ask you ask God Almighty alone to guide
you try that right now say the one who
created me the reality guide me that's
the first step and God Almighty will
guide and facilitate a way for the one
who's looking to be guided
see you next time I hope you enjoyed
this what do I call it vlog spend some
time with you may Allah bless you
Ramadan I Salam alaikum peace be with
you